all right we're welcoming back uh sort
of an old friend to the show i guess
although sometimes he throws me off the
show jessie lee peterson is joining us
he is host of the jesse lee peterson
show
he's host of the fallen state which i
visited the studio when i was in los
angeles
uh and jesse are you are you uh are you
a pastor as well do i recall that
correctly are you a christian pastor
i am yes you are and what what
denomination
non-denominational christian okay and i
remember
that your studio in la people may find
this interesting
is it also some kind of christian
counseling center
do i remember that correctly where you
counsel young men
yeah but uh not in the studio we have i
have my offices
upstairs and so we we council and in
house and
by skype or telephone or by phone
whatever is easy for the folks
that's fascinating and so now you're
you're not like a therapist right you're
not a social worker or a psychologist or
anything like that
no just a counselor okay and that's
in california that's an unregulated
credential right anybody can use that
term
well you have to you have to be a
minister or pastor or something like
that
and you can do counseling under the head
in them of your ministry
wow and that insurance doesn't cover
that right it does
it does in california you can go to a
counselor who's just a minister and
it's considered a medical visit 100
as a matter of fact it's better that you
come to me than the people with the
degrees
well that's an opinion that's an opinion
but i'm concerned with the legal piece
if you notice and by the way we are
friends david even though i had to
throw you off one day we still sometimes
i throw my friends off okay
what up but uh it's better that you come
to me than a person with a degree
because
if you notice that educated people are
dumb they have no
sense i've not noticed that i've not
noticed that and they end up
giving the people after they run after
the just before the people run out of
money
they give them medication because the
therapists
uh the trained therapists and counselors
psychologists and psychiatrists have no
common sense
but a lot of the people you just
mentioned a lot of the people you just
mentioned
can't even prescribe medication so
psychologists don't prescribe
neither do social workers so what you're
saying you know you know it's not true
right
well what i'm saying is that people with
degrees on dummies
they have no common sense they're just
okay someone told them
i gotcha all right now now i understand
because the first thing you said is
literally
impossible because they can't prescribe
but i'm glad you hear that
you're glad to hear that good and you
can't prescribe you're not prescribing
anything i'm
guessing no no no no okay good um so
listen jesse
we're on the precipice here of an
election and the reason i wanted to talk
to you
is to figure out on because you're such
a master of
policy you know economics and
trade and all of these things i wanted
to figure out where you
are on trump and policy so let just to
begin with i mean you you approve of the
job the president is doing right
he's done an amazing job thus far in
spite of the children of the lie
yeah and the children of the line the
liberal media the democratic party the
never trumpers
the right of republicans the black race
hustlers and the radical homosexuals
they have been against him but in sp and
our enemies
overseas as well but in spite of that
he's done an amazing job so uh four more
years of the great white hope
yeah and when you talk about the job
that trump has done
just to pick something to really dig
into and make this um you know i want to
take the interview seriously and
you know hopefully it won't devolve the
way some of the prior interviews have
let's take economics and taxation for
example
do you like the trump tax plan and if so
what do you like about it
well that's why i like the fact that he
is cut back on taxes and giving more
money to the workers
rather than taking it i like the fact
that he
um has made it easier for small
businesses to get going
even though we have a chinese virus
situation right now so the economy
has stopped a little bit but it's
starting to come back
and dude but let's pick something
let's pick one thing what has trump done
to make
it easier for businesses to get going
by cutting back on so many rules and
regulations that the democrat had
established
like what what's an example of such a
such a rule i don't have anything in
mind
right now yeah but a lot of the rules of
regulation that was preventing
uh uh small businesses from starting
yeah have been taken away by the great
white hope what would be but so give me
just i don't i know that there's dozens
and dozens but what's one such rule
that was taken away that now makes it
easier to start a business
nothing come to mind right now it is
there anything that you can remember
even seeing at any time nothing come to
mind
nothing wow that's amazing amazing
yeah uh okay all right so let's stick
with economics just for a moment
what do you think the top marginal tax
rate should be for for top earners
good question man i don't know i haven't
thought about it at this point
is it too high or too low currently so
now
i'm sorry wouldn't you say your phone
went off for a minute what'd you say
i said do you think the current top
marginal tax rate is too high or too low
i'm not sure at this time david you're
not sure so how do you know
that trump's tax plan is good if you
don't even know what tax rates are and
how he changed them
well because i have not been focusing on
that lately i have more important things
to think about and
do that has not been one of my primary
focus at this point all right well let's
take a different topic then
donald trump made a huge deal during the
campaign
in 2016 and now about trade
trade with china trade with mexico and
canada
do you believe that donald trump has
fulfilled his campaign promises on trade
or do you believe he has fallen
short he has not uh fallen short but he
has
not completed them at this time that's
why we have to one of the reasons but
not the only that we have to do
four more years yeah so he can finalize
the trade deals that he
is working on what would you like to see
him do
on trade that he's not yet done to make
sure that america is being treated
fairly in trade deals and that we're not
giving away or being used as we have
been in the past
in those ways interesting so donald
trump yesterday at his rally
said that he fixed china that now china
has to treat us fairly because he fixed
it and he says that he fixed
canada and mexico with usmca
so they're now treating us fairly so
who's left that's not treating us
fairly on trade did he mention that
yesterday i didn't hear that at all
it was either yesterday or i mean the
rallies are blending together maybe it
was the day before did he say who
who was left that he had to deal with no
i'm asking you
who do you think is still treating us
sometimes they call the white house
sportsman
yeah sports person and they can answer
those questions for you i have no idea
well but i guess what i'm trying to
understand jesse is
government so you're asking me the wrong
questions right but so
you you asserted that you like a lot of
what trump accomplished on trade right
but believe that but hold on jesse hold
on jesse though
no hold on jesse hold on i'm asking
about david you have to
call the white house you're gonna have
plenty of time to answer let me just get
the question out
you asserted that you like some of what
he did on trade
but you want to see him do more i'm
saying what more should he do
i have no idea david you know he knows
so you should call them and ask them
you're asking me the wrong questions
okay that's that's interesting because
it sounds like you don't really know
what's going on
not just totally no no okay that area
i'm not concerned about that either
i'm gl well but you mentioned it as
something you liked so it must concern
you
what the president is doing and hasn't
done this more and bringing jobs back
as far as some of the changes he's done
but for more information you should
contact them
but you don't think you should be in any
way
you should contact them don't you
understand are you it's hard to
understand
no it's coming it's actually coming
through clearer than that
if you want to continue you need to move
on because you're asking the wrong
person
so you're a very strong advocate of the
president
and you very powerfully you powerfully
say on your program
people should vote for him but you seem
unable to articulate what he's actually
done
by those things you just asked i have no
idea i'm not even
concerned okay how would you tackle
climate change jesse
no such thing okay and and
elaborate on that it's a made-up lie by
the liberal democrats
in order to get more money in power and
control the people climate change is
fake
you know in some countries
uh climate change is much less
politicized in other words you might
have scientists who are
conservative and scientists who are
liberal
and they all agree about it why do you
think
in other countries even the conservative
scientists accept the science on climate
i have no idea but in america climate
change is fake
in them in america maybe in those maybe
in those
i don't know for sure but maybe in those
other countries they're controlling the
people
because the people weak minded and they
allow themselves to be controlled by
lies
interesting and and that's happening
that's happening in other countries
well maybe i don't know for sure what's
going on in other countries but in my
country
is climate change is fake are you um
you're you're of course in coastal
california which is the place that
if the sea level continues to rise could
have flooding problems
we've also seen a number of prominent
conservatives abandon california for
more
politically conservative parts of the
country is that something you're
thinking about
about abandoning california yeah because
it's so liberal
not at this time it i mean at one time
for the first time in all my
i've been here since 1968 yeah it did
cross my mind but i'm not ready to pack
up and run
at this time i believe that america uh
california will come back to become a
conservative state because the democrats
have done a good job in screwing it up
when it comes to illegal aliens
homelessness
not a lot down from the so-called
chinese virus
the fires the high taxes uh
and even with all of that jesse you
still prefer it to other conservative
parts of the country after decades
that's interesting
i i because i love california i like the
the well it used to be beauty beautiful
at one time
i like the opportunities in california
and just an amazing state
we just need to get the democrats out
and replace them with conservative
republicans
right and you think you'll like it even
more if republicans take over california
if they're conservatives and not rhinos
i believe that we can put it back to
a normal state of being prior to the
democrats completely taking over
what's something really specific in
terms of the law
that you'd like to see california do
differently it could be anything it
could be on you know
guns it could be on economic paul like
what would you like to see
changed in california from a legal
standpoint well number one i would like
to see
the uh borders close shut down
completely so the illegals cannot come
in
i would like to see laws that says we
will not and cannot and shall not pay
for
so-called health care for illegal aliens
or anyone who is
unwilling to work for themselves i would
love to see lower taxes for
uh home buyers land buyers and people
like that
um the restriction as far as
the second amendment right they need to
take their hands off our second
amendment we have the right to buy
bullets
wow to own whatever god we want and has
as
many as we want i will change some of
those rules
um i uh we're going to go to a break on
the podcast but my full conversation
with with jessie lee peterson will of
course be published to our youtube
channel
in full no edits jesse you know we never
edit anything you say
listen you mentioned you want to shut
down the border i'm curious
a lot of americans in california
arizona texas they go to mexico for
medical care
because they can't afford it here in the
united states do you want to shut that
down as well do you want to stop
americans from going to mexico for
medical care
i don't no i don't want to stop them
from going they can go
anywhere they want to for it but i don't
want
us to have to pay for illegal alien
health care in our country
and we should i mean in our state or in
our country
ah okay but we definitely should not be
a sanctuary
state or city i would definitely change
that but you could be
free you are american you can go
wherever you want to get healthier
that's up to you
should americans be more free than
citizens of other countries
america should be we are the light of
the world
and we absolutely should be free it's up
to the other folks in their country
to determine how much freedom they want
but if other countries determine that
their citizens should be as free as
americans should be you have no problem
with that right
if that's what they want they can do
whatever they want in their country i'm
only concerned about my country
um speaking of of of our country jesse
um when we watch your program and we
hear these
impassioned critiques of the things that
are going wrong in the united
states that you issue um
one can't help but wonder what country
has it right
when you look around the world jesse
because you have so many
you know criticisms of the united states
what country do you see
that is getting it right on certain
issues that you think we should emulate
we shouldn't emulate any of those
countries they are to emulate
us okay we call we are the best and the
greatest country on this side of heaven
we are the example of what other
countries should become
but let me see if i can rephrase it okay
even though the democrats have
screwed up a lot the president is making
it great again
right but we are the example for the
rest of the world
okay so let me see if i can frame it in
a different way
you point to a lot of things that you
say democrats have done
very poorly and you've said that this
includes in california but also
around the country what examples would
you point to
to say to the democrats here's how you
should do it
is there a state that's doing it right
is there a country that
isn't they're not saying a country's
better than us but for example like is
saudi arabia getting it right
on capital punishment in your mind or is
north korea getting it right when it
comes to how to control the media do you
see anything you like there
the first thing that comes to mind that
the democrats has clearly done to our
country
is to divide the races in order to
uh uh conquer divide and conquer
and that is they have lied and said that
there is such thing as police brutality
racism white supremacists okay uh
uh uh all this stupidism that they'll
come up with
those are lies and the incident doesn't
exist in our country but they have
managed to use those
words in order to divide and conquer
beauty i would love to get rid of those
words and let the people know
that there's no ism it's either right or
wrong good or evil you're either on the
side of evil
or your underside of good and so that we
can become one nation
right under god again i will unite
the country in that way the first thing
i would do i love it so
when you say you want to get rid of
those words would you
ban the words would you make them would
you outlaw the teaching of those words
in school like schools can't use the
word racism how do you do that
i definitely wouldn't ban the word did
you say i'm sorry you said you would you
would or you would not you wouldn't
not but i would not allow the schools to
teach that to the children and brainwash
them
got it in order to do what we see that
they have done to the young folks
already
got it so school curriculum could not
include the word
racism that's right because it doesn't
exist
it's a it's a brainwashing technique to
use to divide
we are americans we are america we are
one nation
under god yeah and those words tend to
divide us
would you ban any so you don't want any
isms
taught in school no racism no sexism no
homophobia is um
no white supremacism and no
anti-semitism no islam
is either right or wrong good or evil
now i'm sure you also then
would would say that when republicans
use the isms
socialism and communism that's also
divisive right and wrong
because there is socialism look at the
democratic party
look at the mindset of most black people
they are socialists
in their mind in that they allow the
government to do for them
and tell them when and where and how
rather than doing for themselves
as a matter of fact that's what the
democrats want to do by way of the
government is to control the people
by giving them things and thinking for
them and providing
rather than providing the folks to
provide them for themselves
who is a prominent democrat whose
associate communism
exists who who is a prominent democrat
that's a communist
wow that's a good one um
you know those four radical women that
uh who are those stupid women
the one from new york and detroit what
what yeah the squad those are perfect
example of
communism i can't think of the name
they're so stupid
so they and and the cortez i believe
from new york
that's a nut case i don't even
understand why anyone would even
listen to her right less more vote for
her but you have the other one out of
what yeah illihan omar
and another and what uh what communists
what communist policy have they
advocated for
they want to take care of the people
they want to take care of the people
ain't for the people they want to give
free health care free
everything for the folks not all are
they evil
it's pure communism jesse do you know
what communism
is yes what is it the people
uh when someone else wants to control
you it's about controlling
other people communism is controlling
other people that's interesting
that's interesting um okay
uh you you've really said a lot here and
and you know i'm doing the best i can to
to sort of keep up with all of it
tell me when you look at uh donald trump
you've you've told us all
of the things that you think he's done
great except then you said you don't
really care about those things like
economics and trade and all of that
stuff
i care about them but that's not my
thing i don't pay a lot of attention to
that
right so here's my question are you able
to identify
anything you don't like that donald
trump has done
i don't know how much i'll agree with
him on letting the inmates out of the
prisons
which mm-hmm are which inmates are those
which are which inmates are those
you know how they let a lot of the uh uh
prisons out by saying that they were
there because they sold pot or
their crime wasn't bad enough to keep
them
in prison some kind of dumb stuff like
that you don't know how much i support
that because i haven't had time to
really
look into that i just feel that
if you do the crime you should do the
time and it doesn't matter what color
you are
right i'm in total support of that
and did you yeah and one other one that
might
might make you feel good on the inside
um
i don't like the fact that when he right
now
there's a position opened on the u.s
supreme court yes
i don't like the fact that he is uh
nominated a woman
just because it's a woman for america it
should be the best
qualified person and not even say hey
i'm gonna put a woman there all right
i'm gonna put a man in there i'm gonna
put a black there i'm gonna put
a homosexual there or anything like that
but i'm gonna look and find the best
person that's qualified
right and that's the person i'm going to
put in that position that is the
american way
so it's just it's sort of identity
politics that trump is playing in a
sense
on this part i don't like that no that's
interesting that's very interesting
certainly right into the hands of the
democrats
when you do that and you and i know that
the democratic party is an evil party
it has no chris uh godly values at
all you know what's weird about that
jesse he i
as a you're a man of faith right and
you're a christian uh
counselor and you know all of this stuff
we also have an entrepreneur academy
when we're teaching young men
how to start their own businesses or if
they already started
we helped them enhance the business i
started a credit union where we loaned
them the money and they came back with
small interest
we uh we've been around for 30 years now
bond the brotherhood's organization of a
new destiny
right but my question for the family
about rebuilding a man
because most males today are better
bells
right men so we're showing them how to
overcome being a beta male
okay so i was trying to keep this from
being a cartoonish farce but but
it's it's not clear that that's possible
but to get back to the
the sort of um religious question that
you brought up
when i look at donald trump and joe
biden this is
nope this is not looking at politics
this is just looking at religion like if
i were a voter who cared about religion
i look at biden he's been a devout
catholic his entire life
he's gone to church since he was a kid
he knows scripture he
understands catholic teachings and then
i look at trump
and trump never went to church until he
decided to run for president
never read a bible doesn't even know how
to hold the bible
if you ask me which is the religious
president who's the christian
the candidate not president isn't it
obviously joe biden
no it's not go by i mean satan could
quote the scripture for you
a thing can go to a catholic church okay
satan can hold up the bible and there is
no particular way of holding the bible
that's a dumb idea
wow you don't hold the bible wherever
you want to hold the bible okay
and that's so dumb i can't even believe
that people even mention that wow
well joe biden is a very weak beta male
and just because he went to a catholic
look at the pope
the pope is ten the pope where a
beautiful gown
oh the pope he goes out and pretend he
want to greet the people
but if you touch his hand he's gonna
slap it away and he knows the bible he
he went to catholic school in college
right just like
just because you go to church or read
the bible it doesn't make you be
it doesn't mean that you're a christian
christianity better than joe bide to
ever
think of what a christian is nobody
doesn't even know he's in america right
now
which uh which christian value do you
think donald trump most strongly
embodies
perfect love for who all people
wow wow that's incredible jesse
amazing that's amazing are you kind of
i'm getting the sense that you're not
really that into catholicism is that is
that accurate
no i'm not i know i know a bit more
about it
now than i did while growing up because
uh that wasn't in my area where i grew
up yeah but i'm learning that it's a
waste of time and that the pope is
ticked
sorry the pope what was that word the
pope is what tit
he's upset always tips
um just to kind of circle back around
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male
what are we talking about here there are
males
most men today yeah male they think
and act like a woman they are emotional
they are mentally off they have no
logic and that's a beta male they go
along with homosexuality hold on but
holy whoa whoa jesse well we gotta oh
that's a lot
that's a lot hold on agree with
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male died
but another baby doesn't because he's a
logical thinking
he guides you in the right way to go
instead of going along with wrongdoing
so you said that one of the ways in
which
a beta male is like a woman is that a
woman has
has mental problems so you're you're
saying that
all women and some beta males that they
have mental problems is that what you
said
all women who have not grown up close to
their fathers
have uh uh uh illogical mindset
wow they're up and down in the way they
think and feel and they're
controlled by the darkness of their
imagination
likewise males males who have not
overcome their mothers and returned to
their fathers
they have illogical mindsets just like
their mother and just like women
so it's almost like you've you've almost
taken
a bit of a freudian approach and
like perverted it into sort of like your
your your
christian view of that is is that am i
sort of on to the the
the ideology here well i have not
perverted even god said that we must be
born again
you were born of the woman and anyone
who's born of the woman
is dying but those who are born of the
spirit
of god are living and so i didn't make
that up god did that you have to
call him fraudulent or whatever is this
um is this the type of stuff you talk
about in these christian counseling
sessions with young men
you can hear that on my radio show if
you're going to jessalynpeterson.com or
rebuildingdemand.com
right because i get calls about these
issues from around the world
yeah and the same thing is happening is
that
their mothers have turned them away from
their fathers by playing victim
and pretending that the father was a bad
guy she was just the humble new woman
have nothing to do with she was a victim
turning the children away from their
fathers
recreating them and her image and they
she caused the children become angry
and once you become angry you become
just like the person that you're angry
at
that's why in today's america
the men are acting just like the women
because the fathers are not protecting
them from the mothers
what you said unfortunately at this
point
most men are beta what percentage of
all american men right now give me the
numbers what percentage are alpha
what percentage are beta that's a really
good question i don't know the
percentage
i do know that an abnormal amount of men
today
obey the males yeah especially
millennials
and disease and some of the older
generation as well but
most millennial men and disease are beta
male because there has been an
attack among boys and men for the last
60 to 70 years and the whole idea is to
destroy the image of the male
and urchin in the image of the woman
which is not good for
family is not good for a country
ballpark not good for the woman because
the woman are not created to lead
they are created to follow women don't
have love
they receive love from the man who
received it from god
um he's god in christ christ and man
yeah over woman and woman over children
that's the order
reverse that order and put the woman
over the man and that would never work
that that that's a that's a little
nebulous to me but so would you ballpark
it
are we talking 10 alpha 20 percent alpha
what
ballpark it i absolutely don't know the
amount but i
am the number the percentage but i am
stunned as how many men
are like women nowadays i mean i
literally counsel with men
and women across the world and on my
show i get tons of calls from men
and women around the world right and
same thing that's happening women are
destroying
and they're starting in the home and
then in the schools and government and
all over the place
that's interesting i'm trying to imagine
what what kind of person would say
i'm struggling with something let me
call
jessie lee peterson for help i'm trying
to put myself in the mindset of such an
individual it's hard to imagine
any person that has examined him or
herself
yeah and they know something is wrong
and they hear me talking about it
they will call me to get a better
understanding of how to overcome it
but most people are not seekers they are
just
out in the world going along with
whatever they hear or see
they have no sense to think for
themselves
so it's just a few because most people
are taking a wide road that leads to
destruction for example you have
men who are with women and the women are
controlling them
right those are the type of men that are
not
seeking to overcome and return in your
mind the man should always control the
woman right
he should always be the head of a woman
absolutely
otherwise it's not going to work jesse
listen
you really said it all uh i i do want to
just ask about one more thing
our audience may or may not know you're
you're in your 70s
are what are you drinking pomegranate
what are you doing
in order to keep that glow i don't have
any anger in my heart
i only have love which come from god and
when you don't have anger you're not
stressed out you're not worried you're
not
having suicidal thought you're not
comparing yourself to others
you're not trying to be like anyone else
you are yourself
you're in a perfect peaceful place
within yourself
so you're not comparing yourself to
anyone when you don't have anger that's
why you have to overcome anger if you
want perfect peace
what so it's not like you've switched to
turkey bacon or you eat a lot of fruit
or have
kind of some special skin it's just
you're just not an angry guy
no i don't have anger so i'm not under
stress
and you don't attribute any of it to
diet
no i do work out you know i exercise i
eat
in moderation now but i do it because
you know i have a self-control now i
don't have to give in to all that stuff
and plus i don't have anger so i'm not
trying to fulfill my
an ego right most people who are out of
control in the way they eat
have sex use pot and drink they have an
ego problem they have an
anger problem that's why we show people
how to overcome that anger
so they can have peace within themselves
then they would do all things in
moderation
wow and are you are you off sex
altogether now
i am you are because i'm not only
because i'm not married
if i was married i would not be offset
wow that's a revelation i think the
audience will find compelling that's
very very interesting
um and you think that you're not married
right i am not married
are you obsessed or you haven't said
well i'm very much on sex
you haven't said well i don't even know
the term the term wedlock to me is not a
term that's part of my life
wedlock sounds locked it sounds bad
you're not married right
i'm not married so you have obsessed out
of wedlock i just don't know
what wedlock is that's amazing you've
never heard that word
yeah it's just a weird word it sounds
like a moralizing word
it means that anyone who is not married
and they are having sex out of wedlock
yeah it's not good because the woman who
was having sex at a wedlock it's a [ __ ]
and the man who's having sex out of
wedlock is a [ __ ] maker
and that's not good for either one wow
that is something we're gonna have we're
gonna have to go back to the drawing
board on that because that's what you
ever marry a slap
you know that we discussed that word on
your show that's it's not a term i use
so it's hard for me to engage with it
seriously
right but i used to any woman that's
having sex out of weight loss it's a
[ __ ] would you marry a [ __ ]
i reject the premise what do you mean i
reject the premise of the question
what do you mean come on jesse
i don't understand what you mean yeah
and you and i don't understand what you
mean
so you rejected the fact that a woman
who is having a female who's having sex
out of wedlock is a [ __ ]
i i reject the entire framing of this
issue
what do you mean come on why are you
rejecting the truth
your truth is nonsense but that makes
you sound like a beta male i don't want
to use beta mail on you today you've
used it on me so many times i think i
could take it once more
do you believe that any man who has sex
out of wedlock is a slap maker
no i don't those are not terms i use
which is most impor
important to you values or education
i i don't believe that it's an either or
i don't see those as two sides of the
same uh
the same seesaw so to speak so you don't
believe there's a difference between
more values and
they're two different things in what way
moral values have are a totally
different thing than education you're
acting i know that you're one or the
other
which one do you prefer more values or
education
it's just not a choice like that it's
not a more it's not a choice well it
should be
because people who are educated have no
values oh okay
all right well jesse you've really said
it all
we've been speaking with jessie lee
peterson
um now the host not only
of the jesse lee peterson show also host
of the fallen state
a christian counselor insurance will
reimburse he told us
although i want to have a call with
someone in california to confirm
that um jesse it's always
fascinating speaking with you it's uh
always amazing being on with you i got
to bring you back onto my show
yes and i want all people
to understand that they must be born
again they got to overcome mama
and return to the father right even god
said that there's a time
there will come a time when i will
return the children to the father
meaning adult and young to him
and then fathers to the children because
of that spiritual order of god in christ
christ in man man over woman and woman
over children
nothing else is going to work but that
order and any male that's following a
woman
he's gonna he's gonna suffer it's never
gonna work out wow because anytime you
listen to a woman you will suffer
okay we're gonna get that all evaluated
translated and uh and notated so that we
can do some deeper thinking about it but
jesse i i really do appreciate your time
today
i was i appreciate you having me on
david and i will send joelle
over for more clarity all right
okay joelle i don't know who that is but
we'll wait for him